[Music]
Marvel's officially full of themselves
subject's audience 232nd logo in order
for you to know why the Avengers are
here you needed to watch agents of
shield which I have neither the time nor
the patience to sit through so I can
understand the movie also a movie makes
me do research so that can figure out
Agent Coulson is behind this Avengers op
which is confusing because he died in
the last of interest movie or did he
hears Thor doing what he does best
punching and kicking dudes glorious shot
of all the Avengers in one frame is
absolutely ruined by the complete and
total pointlessness of this opening
battle language swear police six seconds
of black widow doing incomprehensible
action things no one else is gonna deal
with the fact that cap just said
language just goes to show how horrible
Hydra is or more how good the heroes are
that they can endlessly crack jokes
during these battles concentrates fire
on the weak once this is precisely why
the Avengers shouldn't have any weak
ones aka Black Widow and Hawkeye send in
your own Legion what you were attacking
this pivotal enemy base without five
autonomous Ironman robots assisting you
before now what the hell for to any of
the Avengers even need to be here right
now this movie should have been
subtitled the age of wasted resources
this quadrant so save something you
sicko pians can totally understand in
English we have enhanced in the field
and then that's all we ever see of
Quicksilver during the entire battle if
you're simply trying to escape why
bother showing himself if he's fighting
then why does it completely disappear
from the action indeed yay and only have
to do is randomly push some part of the
wall and it opens this movie suggests
that between the last film and this one
Black Widow figured out some magical
interpersonal hand wiping connection
with the Hulk she can exploit to get
Hulk back to banner status which is some
bolt and here's yet another scene that
makes no sense
Scarlet Witch shows up hits cap with red
cgi and then leaves to allow cap to
simply beat Strucker
let's point also girl who's been
experimented on and held captive decides
to defend those who experimented on her
and held her captive
sure here we have time for visions of
the future there was a time when those
were called previews and they came
before the movie not during also Scarlet
Witch freaks out Iron Man with a vision
of dead Avengers instead of just you
know killing it does anyone else find it
unnerving that these two played husband
and wife the last time we saw them now
they're twins
kind of creepy right
[Music]
well damn beats is even showing up in
the Maria Callas music videos he's been
after this thing since shield collapsed
but why wasn't Loki's sceptre on top of
the stark tower at the end of the last
movie did none of you go and get it I
don't want your damn TV show so I can't
you at least explain how the fucking
scepter got into the wrong hands again
for us movie fans huh I will never see
this building as anything other than a
blue jay he's fast and she's weird movie
thinks a throwaway punchline will make
me forget it does nothing to explain
scarlet witch's abilities but movie is
wrong well Nanda was the end of Iron Man
3 and the promise to destroy all the
suits I guess since pepper isn't in this
movie if she can't object what if next
time aliens roll up to the club and they
will they couldn't get past the bouncer
well do they have suitable fake IDs we
can only do it while we have the scepter
here that's three days give me three
days nor decided that three days of
revelry was an order after a battle that
took like ten minutes one of this
movie's biggest flaws is having Tony
Stark behaving as though he can create
artificial intelligence without it
instantly going rogue against humanity
so Tony has never seen terminator the
matrix and that's the end of Jarvis I
think I don't know
so no pepper she's not coming what about
Jane this is the only world in which
party guests we're too expensive to show
up you find a place in Brooklyn yet I
don't think I can afford a place in
Brooklyn wait you're a celebrity working
in a highly funded secret government
agency and you can't afford a place in
Brooklyn they paying in 1940's money
neither was Omaha Beach blondie stop
trying to scare us in this movie's
unwarranted Stan Lee cameo Stan Lee
we'll play one of the guys that storm
Normandy because of course he will hey
just what the story needed a romantic
angle involving Romanoff and Bruce
Banner the plot thickens Hammer
measuring contest also why does it take
three hours for an AI like Ultron to
fully realize itself take control of a
robot and attack the party nobody gets a
laugh out of Banner trying to lift
Thor's hammer but dodges geek orgasm
question of what would happen if Banner
were in full-on hulk mode while trying
to lift it and widow oh that's not a
question I need answered thank God
my sexual fantasies would have taken a
huge hit if she did Ultron has played
enough to wait until the non-important
party guests have left the building to
start his attack also why did he pick
the damaged suit to download into when
there are plenty of perfectly good suits
to do that
Romanoff thinks that mere guns can shoot
down these indestructible iron suits
these iron suits are Tony's suits right
did they suddenly forget how to aim when
they become bad guys wait so one wallet
from cap shield and these iron Legion
BOTS explode into bits are you telling
me Tony Stark built a fleet of bitch
BOTS
[Music]
Ultron is in the cloud also an evil
robot in a Marvel movie I honestly
thought I'd never see the day Ultron
cleared up use the internet as an escape
hatch
he used the what - what now you may have
forgotten during that confusing battle
that Rhodes was hit with Ultron's pulse
bolt crashed through a window and fell
about 50 feet into a metal walkway down
below but sure he's just gotten out on
his shoulder trail went cold about a
hundred miles out you mean an Iron Man
soup trail
what kind of trail do those leave do you
look for broken twigs and footprints and
if it's that easy how'd you lose it I
know this church is in the exact center
of the city
Dillon gives us some sort of history
lesson two up you're more interesting in
smart cliche but sooner or later every
man shows himself this accent but I saw
Starks fear I knew it would control him
make him self-destruct it might have
been easier to just kill him but the
psychology experiment is a lot more fun
smaller people children lost the word
they're great because an AI robot would
somehow forget the word children in the
midst of planning a worldwide
annihilation makes a whole big how
parents go in
wait so magneto went out like a bitch in
this time would we wait for two days for
Tony Stark to kill us during which time
we filmed our love scene for Godzilla
Owen I really should be good enough on
his own to do whatever plan he's
dreaming up with the multiple robots and
full range access to the Internet but
how could Marvel pass up yet another
villainous team-up they've worked so
well for their movies in the past based
on a guy Tony knew one time out of the
thousands connected to Strucker they
managed to turn this one lead into the
exactly they need to find Ultron
cuttlefish deep-sea fish they make lots
this guy lives this is the point of the
script that every bad guy needs to pass
on some sort of trivial knowledge to the
Maximoff twins so they could win Slumdog
Millionaire I guess I only deal with the
man in charge why did all Tron bother
sending the human mutants first if he
himself was there was it just for the
Whammy visual cuz I think it was
the guy with this gun clearly has no
chance to kill Ultron but Scarlet Witch
is there to stop him just so it seems
she's not completely useless
oh we need something for Black Widow to
do I know send in a bunch of people
human soldiers right now
Avengers two steals the suspended
animation Quicksilver scene from x-men
Days of Future oh wait does Thor see
Quicksilver is that when he throws the
hammer here also the one guy with
superpowers who clearly doesn't need any
help besides I need Thor's hammer let's
do this stay down kid
yeah stay down and I trust you'll just
stay there while we go kick some more
ass only now why not earlier
why even play physical games at all
huzzah more dream sequences done the
whole mind control thing not a fan talk
I have a weights being mind-controlled
simply because the filmmakers wanted to
tell a joke comic book hero movie
splices frames from center stage into
the final print Captain America's
Scarlet Witch induced flashback will
consist of recreating a scene from swing
kids are you ready for our dogs well
this is a fun cameo but why is Scarlet
Witch giving the Avengers happy memories
I want the big one luckily the Avengers
parked their plane in an easily viewable
area so that Scarlet Witch can control
honk which is just an excuse for the
whole Buster scene which this movie
clearly needed oh yeah I'm an an Ultron
have totally been fighting the last five
minutes while I watched fictional mind
flashbacks I'm calling in Veronica this
is the second time this movie that Tony
has called in some previously unknown
support part of his arsenal for dramatic
effect Tony Stark designed a whole cage
that only lasts 30 seconds so Tony has a
suit that helps him defeat Hulk the most
undefeatable guy in all of Marvel war
but somehow doesn't deem that superior
suit worthy of wearing during normal
Ultron warfare why isn't the whole
poster armor the default armor
Hulkbuster armor is clearly bad ass but
if Black Widow can solve Hulk with a
couple of arm touches and a hypno phrase
then why didn't everyone learn that
never mind these innocent people here
pay attention to the spectacle dammit I
mean weird they trying to out
transformers 3 Man of Steel here let me
suggest that even in Hulk mode banner is
somehow able to see and feel sorrow for
his terrible Hulk actions so that punch
knocked him out ah this is what we all
paid for right the Avengers of Medicine
County luckily for Hawkeye the Avengers
are disgraced and now his house
functions as a means to make him matter
more yeah fury help me set this out when
I join and even though Captain America
Winter Soldier established that fury and
all of shield were compromised somehow
this little farmers paradise still went
unnoticed pretty sweet right I saw
something in my dream what dream I need
answers to what I would find him here
wait what I'm so confused
what about dr. banner what does happen
going on too long and also about how the
movie to be precise oh I totally support
your avenging hog movie teasers
potentially contentious discussion
between Rogers and stark but erroneously
thinks we'd rather spend time with Hall
guys marriage yes sir - but why second
Avengers film suddenly decides Hawkeye
is somehow the moral center of this
group of crime fighters which is stupid
rushed forced and stupid just in case
you confused it with soul nor wig you
still think you're the only monster on
the team smart people know she's talking
about being an efficient killer not that
she can't have babies however should we
send the fact that coming right on the
heels of a revelation that she's sterile
this script was a little tone deaf about
that every time someone tries to win a
war before it starts innocent people die
wait but what about when people try to
win a war after it starts do innocent
people still die then goes I think they
do live favor
Jesus is there any reason for this guy
to pop out of nowhere in the scene who's
here that he'd be hiding from in a barn
Ultron says the Avengers are the only
thing between him and his mission yet he
decided not to kill them while they were
all confined on a boat and confused by
Scarlet Witch
most phone's going to evolve how has
anyone been in contact with Helen show
who water of science remember when the
individual movies got you excited about
the Avengers now it's the Avengers job
to get you excited about individual
movies which in turn will preview the
next ones coming soon Marvel previews
the movie the water spirits accept me I
can return to my dream and find what I
missed
of course it's almost too easy in case
you confused it with us a little Korea
attacking Avengers jet drops off cap and
only cap about a half mile from where he
ultimately needs to be mostly just so
the film can have a cool establishing
shot dr. Joe why is she not dead she's
got a huge gash in her chest real power
is inside the cradle Jim oh Jesus more
fucking things I'm gonna have to
remember now with all the artifact
sectors gems minerals and inventions in
these movies
things right in the year thankfully
since thawing out cap has seen Matrix
Reloaded first off these people are dead
knowing what we know about Captain
America and his unbelievable strength
second off why the are these people
driving behind this van where they see
cap dangling out the back door and
obvious don't drive behind this is going
on how stupid is it that with all the
Avengers the best plan here is for a jet
to trail cap in case he gets into
trouble so that it can drop a powerless
black widow down in a motorcycle to pick
up a shield first off you know second
off your idea is to shoot the road
instead of her what the hell for this
does absolutely nothing to Ultron but
sure enough the guards come out of the
truck exactly as the Avengers need them
to I'm sending the package to you how do
you want me to take it
well me and everyone else who just
thought of a sex joke is going to help
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch show up on
this train out of nowhere they
completely abandon Ultron earlier so
where the hell were they hiding when
they said all right this train is where
we'll finally get that rat bastard well
someone saw spider-man two I know Tony
was at the internet hub place in Norway
but he can't Iron Man over here after
that and help out and wasn't that like
last night ya know everybody on this
train except those with super powers
should be totally dead Elijah price will
be very interested to know this but in
this movie he's Nick Fury so I could be
confusing my movies again Korean Aaron
would like to take the subway tragedy
excuse to remind you how awesome their
air travel services cradle did you get
it
stark will take care of it no he won't I
still just wanna know where he is
scattered dumped his memory but not his
protocols whatever Bull helps you sleep
at night when you ex machina character
back to life
we're not scientists we're monsters
buddy this is the speech one man of
science gives another man of science to
convince him to repeat a horribly failed
previous experiment paging all real
scientists how pissed off does this make
you oh he also kept Black Widow alive
instead of killing her Ultron is full of
bizarre and dumb moves God he's gonna
keep her alive even longer it's not like
the Avengers need a reason to attack him
ah screw that evil robot I'm going
golfing wait he's got Black Widow it's
on now if Quicksilver isn't doing any
quick silvering right now then why is he
seeing the bullet at Quicksilver speed
sudden Thor's sudden Thor does some bull
and gives birth to vision but I'm not
sure I believe my eyes because this is
the same guy John Nash hallucinate it in
a beautiful mind
artificial intelligence created by a
combination of Ultron banner and stark
knowledge with a little bit of Thor
lighting comes with a free cape let's
before you Jesus I mean why what's the
freaking point
dacovia he's gotten out there too
because Ultron keeps human prisoners and
stuff also if you really think about it
Ultron woke up then disappeared for a
few days to build an even more better
robot so the age of Ultron is at least
80% the age of vision if we're speaking
technically every form he's built every
trace of his presence on the net the net
the net every trace this is some 1990s
internet dialogue if I've ever heard it
because that was awesome as I'll remove
us in for that why not when going into
battle the avengers only trust adidas
Ultron knows we're coming
but does he know win well of course
Ultron knows you're coming to attack if
you do a pre attack maverick style flyby
of his base like this I mean Jesus movie
glosses over how banner is able to
infiltrate Ultron's compound and find
the prison sector undetected oh good
the Avengers are now going to war with a
bunch of robot clones this is sort of
like the ending the first Avengers only
this time they bother to evacuate a city
before destroying it and also it's like
attack of the clones so there's that
again it's just too bad for this movie
that x-men Days of Future Passed
Quicksilver came first because it makes
this a lot less awesome
sorry jaws the scene of Ultron's
machining lifting a chunk of the city up
into the air is awesome it's just too
bad for this movie that x-men Days of
Future past
magneto lifts up the stadium scene came
first because it makes this a lot less
awesome sorry again Joss buddy
sokovia is going for ride man Tony's
back up Jarvis software is super poetic
and vague and maybe on drugs so the
reason Ultron is doing this is because
Jarvis stopped him from accessing
nuclear launch codes and stuff that
would make ending the world a lot easier
but why not just build your own bombs
Ultron clearly has all the knowledge he
needs to do something way easier than
something out of the Lex Luthor Handbook
the action in the finale of age of
Ultron is ridiculously confusing and
ultimately boring as they fight tons of
robot clones all of whom appear to have
no fight in them whatsoever the city's
flying we're fighting an army of robots
and have a bow and arrow none of this
makes sense
look I'm laughing I'm laughing my ass
off of course just because you joke
about your ridiculous plot making no
sense doesn't exactly excuse it either
also Hawkeye would be excellent at
cinemasins
also having your most useless superhero
joke about his uselessness does not
excuse his inclusion in the Avengers
over other heroes with real actual
powers instead of fighting Ultron
Captain America goes about saving one or
two of the 20,000 endangered citizens
makes sense it's amazing with all these
robots everyone has to fight Thor just
happens to be flying by when these cars
go into freefall he's
to save them but guess what many many
more getting murdered by robots right
now while you could save these two
people you'll never wait what cap can
now somehow call his my brain 'i'm
shield back to his arm via telepathy in
this sequence black widow will use taser
knives to kill Ultron BOTS
at the rate of an actual super-powered
individual for you were bothering ya
he's the only one bothering you but
whatever Oh
see if you never explaining hero's
powers like even a tiny bit then you can
get away with having the mind explode a
bunch of enemies in the finale Oh am I
gonna get a view like this um an
airplane a mountain a ride on Iron Man's
back this is a very stupid line written
by a very lost screenwriter it's kind of
amazing that when all this went down
fury was able to find this in a matter
of guessing an hour and was able to fly
it over here just when the heroes needed
it most
sir we have multiple bogies converging
on our starboard flank show em what we
got and what we got turns out to be
discount iron minute as opposed to some
kind of badass anti-aircraft guns you
might expect on an airship like this
alright another character I can confuse
with all the other metal men flying
around right now
furthermore if Rhodey decides to land
anywhere near the Avengers below don't
they accidentally try and kill him since
he looks like all the other silver BOTS
flying around Maria still thinks this is
an appropriate weapon in battles like
this come on this is the best I can do
this is exactly what I wanted all of you
against all of me what are you a
screenwriter the shot pretty much sums
up the entire movie right here useless
robots doing useless things while the
Avengers picked them off do you get a
feeling Ironman could have done this job
himself a scene isn't so much a battle
as it is a modeling session for Avengers
baseball cards in fact I heard if you
cut fast enough the viewer won't be able
to truly settle in and establish on any
one shot of the action thereby confusing
them into thinking it all flows and
makes sense
brilliant how did the Avengers even keep
track of who's kicking whose ass I mean
I got dizzy and threw up just trying to
keep track of one of Ultron soldiers in
the scene
uh-huh remember how you liked it when
Hulk did that in the first movie you
whores laugh it up in the market oh no a
woman we've randomly been seeing a
couple of times during this battle lost
her son damn well there's no way
anyone's ever gonna find Oh twins can
always tell when their twin has been
killed by a terrible screenwriter also
silent no every time Ultron dies in this
movie it's a bunch of nonsense isn't he
still wandering around the internet now
I need you to turn this bird around okay
it's honking pilot all of a sudden so
that was the last Ultron apparently even
though I still have my doubts about that
but what exactly made this the age of
Ultron anyway aren't ages a period of
many many years hey remember me I was in
both Thor movies and the last Avengers
movie and um somehow still the most
forgettable character Marvel ever put
the film Wilda humma you can keep the
monster well as long as there's a good
reason for Tony to be here right now but
not be part of the New Avengers you can
find out what's coming I do it'll
probably take at least three more movies
or so before we can but sure what the
hell is this place
black widows been thinking about Hulk a
long time in this thinking chamber of
some sort Avengers team that has an
all-powerful Scarlet Witch on their side
literally doesn't need any other team
members most especially a dude who can
glide on some metal wings Jesus Oh
[Music]
finally
you want me to take it
[Music]
if we could somehow harness this
lightning chair it into the flux
capacitor
[Music]
remember the desk so you're looking
directly on it get your face very close
to the letter and read the letter aloud
so stand the accumulated filth of all
their sex and murder will foam up around
their waists and all the whores and
politicians will look up and shout save
us
[Music]
I'll whisper yo
[Applause]
[Music]
this is exactly what I wanted all of you
against all of man
and that's because we've been watching
so much Japanese anime on crunchyroll
crunchyroll is an anime streaming
service that offers the largest most
diverse collection of anime series that
you can watch an HD with no ass roll get
you new shows as soon as one after the
air in Japan with subtitles it's safe to
say that's faster than you could pirate
them who didn't believe I could do it
top today the best part you can enjoy it
all free for 30 days when you go to
crunchyroll.com slash cinemasins
yes that's a month of unlimited
professionally subtitled anime manga and
drama titles that you can enjoy on all
your devices
all you have to do is click the link of
the description or head to
crunchyroll.com slash cinemasins to get
started